la chanson de mariah carey à la crise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez un petit doute sur un ami gay
pas gai vous lancez la chanson c'est
direct baddou
et notez que le premier dans ces
documents
oil corp
[Applaudissements]
des exemples aussi pour les gens du foot
qu'on peut être aussi c'est bien mais
c'est bravo c'est vrai bravo alors
effectivement l'argent sont à acquérir à
la one for christmas va devenir l'hymne
officiel de la laponie
est ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que
c'est pas vrai c'est tellement fou dans
les hauteurs se lâche un peu c'est faux
en revanche selon un sondage britannique
le titre de mariah carey viendrait
désignée comme la chanson de noël à la
fois la plus agaçante mais c'est aussi
dans le top 10 des chansons de noël les
plus pas faim pendant les plus agaçantes
voilà je ne vous le dira devant devant
do they know it's christmas de bandar et
l'espace ce qui est très intéressant ces
coeurs il ya encore cinq ans elle
faisait la tournée à la one for
christmas dans le monde entier dans
toutes les villes un peu dans toutes les
capitales du monde
là ça marche moins bien encore un an
pardon ça marche moins du coup cette
année elle l'a fait que aux états unis
mais du coup cette fille ne vit plus que
de sept chansons et de cette tournée non
non non non non à la et des droits
d'auteur du reste même temps que rien
abel a gravi cinq ans ça lui a rapporté
55 millions en tout 55 millions d'euros
55 millions 94 cents par les coop ou si
c'était tino rossi
si elle salue en 94 quand j'entends des
trucs là vingt ans après le vainqueur
serait l enclume santé en fait c'est son
mari qui lui a dit faut sortir un disque
de noël avait 24 ans il lui a dit de
sortir un disque de noël est là il en
sortit ce l'album et il en prit cette
chanson là qui peut rien pour une marque
de chips à la dernière ça lui rapporter
11 millions 1
et c'est encore là n'est rien en 2018 24
décembre la chanson la plus téléchargée
sur dix millions dix millions l'année
dernière de personnes ont écouté le 24
décembre fouet la satanée donc elle
aurait touché 2 millions et demi de
dollars de royalties voilà je la gagne
en amas guinness des records
là cette année c'est quand même
incroyable non au canada depuis qu'un
euro n'a pas été récupéré hier c'est
surtout le succès du film love actually
quand même faudrait appeler qui avait
fait beaucoup pour le succès de cette
chanson dans lequel a été utilisé il y
en a qui font des chansons de noël
maintenant oui tout le monde essaye de
faire des chansons de noël maintenant
c'est la mode parce que tout le monde
espère être une note
exemple alors à temps elle me blesse je
sais pas qui avaient chacune bieber je
peux aussi tout un album de noël mais
qui sait si j'aime faire un album entier
de noël aux états unis ça existe depuis
60 ans dans dix ans on a parlé tout à
l'heure justement des grandes grandes
stars et des grandes grandes voix je
sais que le pascal [ __ ] qui était le
grand patron de universal monde la
france et qui voit là qu'est vraiment
quelqu'un de très connu m'avait dit des
trois plus grandes voix que j'ai connue
de ma vie c'est mariah carey nous
l'avait dit naturel ou whitney houston
et tu va m'aider celle qui chantait
alicia keys dans les amines à alicia
keys dans l'essai minnelli qu'alicia
keys qui chantait ça fait les trois plus
grandes voix qu'il ait rencontré et
reconnaissez que l contrairement aux
autres dont on va parler elle s'est mise
un petit peu à l'écart justement elle
chanta elle fait elle se met un peu
moins en avant on entend un petit peu
moins chaud ça pas mal elle a compris
que parfois et bien faut savoir réussir
une sortie pour avoir une belle carrière